The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
WILLIAM B. BONVILLIAN:
I'm just going
to go very quickly through
the World Economic Forum.
I only wanted you all to glance
at this and get an idea of it,
because what it's in here
for is to show that we're not
the only ones trying to think
about innovation factors,
right.
They are trying
to figure out what
these factors are as they assess
different national economies.
They have a whole global
competitiveness rating
system, which they get
out every other year.
So in 2015, 2016, as
you saw, Switzerland
was number one,
Singapore number two,
and the US was number
three in their rating.
And then they have a
whole series of elements
that they consider in their
global competitiveness
analysis.
So they look at what they
call factor-driven economies,
and the pillars there are
institutions and infrastructure
and macroeconomic
environment and actually
early-stage education
as a pillar in health.
And then efficiency-driven
economies, they call them--
that's higher education, that's
market efficiency for goods,
that's labor market
efficiency, that's
financial market developments,
technology readiness, and so
forth.
And then innovation-driven
economies,
business sophistication,
and innovation capability.
So they have a very
different mix here.
I just wanted to throw in
kind of a comparative way
of other people
looking at the problems
that we're talking about,
and the kind of pillars
that they come
about, and how they
sort different kind of world
economies and organize them.
But a lot of these factors
we've just been talking about.
Kind of the core,
I think, of what
the takeaway is from this
study, and let me get--
you also had Rycroft,
Lily, as well,
so why don't I get Rycroft
out on the table too.
That's Bob Rycroft and Kash.
They did this
piece back in 1999.
And I'm leading in to how do
you look at some of these more
indirect innovation factors?
Because they remain
important, and we're just
going to pick three.
And you know they're looking
at a kind of an element
of innovation organization,
which I think is a core factor,
but they're talking about
kind of a sub-piece of it,
this kind of networking theory
of innovation organization.
I think it's an
intriguing piece.
They argue that we are now at
a stage in the world economy
that complex technologies
drive the economy.
So with complex technologies,
the lone inventor
in the garage working solo--
that's a myth.
That doesn't work anymore,
because the technologies that
lead to innovation are just
too complex, they argue.
So that means that
the traditional focus
of US technology policy on
R&D at particular institutions
and in open markets, that's not
necessarily right anymore, they
argue.
So they say that a much
more self-conscious
networked learning
environment is actually key.
And what does that mean?
Well, complex technologies, we
know, dominate world exports--
82% in 1995 compared
to 43% in 1970.
The rise in complex
products means
a rise in complex organizational
models that goes with it.
The number of
corporate alliances,
corporate interrelationships,
the connectedness
to the actors, becomes all
that much more critical
when the dominant products
are complex technology based.
So as product complexity
grows, the need
for innovative networks grows.
And technological
progress in this phase
really requires that network
learning, integrating,
and applying a
whole wide variety
of new science and technology
knowledge and know-how.
That now becomes key.
Gee whiz, you know, we're
not organized around that.
If these guys are right,
we've got an innovation system
that's organized on a
much earlier idea of how
technologies evolve.
It doesn't necessarily reflect
the reality of the complexity,
and the fact that
the complexity drives
much more complex organizational
system, which includes
networking, they argue.
So they cite George Brown,
who is a great former chairman
of the House Science Committee,
on the point that neglect
of the processes of
knowledge and their diffusion
and application needs to be a
core concern of the innovation
system.
And Brown is talking
about particularly
at the governmental level, the
governmental kind of role here.
There's new kinds of
learning that need
to take place and need
to be organized around.
If you're going
to have this kind
of learning network system--
so a shared network
learning, which
cuts across a series
of institutions,
institutional
engineering that brings
in other parts of the systems,
like the regulatory side,
into the network--
there's got to be a
whole evaluation and what
they call co-evaluation
between complex organizations
and the technologies
that they're developing.
So learning by doing,
learning by using,
learning from scientific
and technology advances,
learning from spillovers,
learning from interaction.
They argue that these are
whole new features of learning
that need to occur that
aren't necessarily accounted
for our current
learning systems.
So they need to be changed
to really accommodate
the new realities of the
way in which innovation is
going to have to get organized.
So that's their proposition.
I thought it was just
kind of a fun read.
It tells us a little more
about the determinism piece
that we were talking
about earlier,
complex technologies demand
new organizational models.
And if Nelson is right,
innovation organization really
amounts to a core direct
innovation factor,
then you know stuff like what
Rycroft and Kash are proposing
becomes significant
in the process.
Lily, it's all yours.
LILY: That was speedy.
WILLIAM B. BONVILLIAN:
Yeah, I'm going
to go high-speed for
the rest of the class.
LILY: First I'll point
out a couple of things
that Bill didn't hit the World
Economic Forum 2015-16 report.
They do mention that, after the
global economic crisis of 2008,
economies are experiencing
increased growth again--
and actually in
the United States,
are experiencing the lowest
unemployment rate since 2008.
However, global
economies are projected
to have slower rates
of economic growth
than they did pre-housing or
global economic crisis of 2008.
And so that sort of
brought me to a question--
it was a question for a couple
of the rest of you as well--
which is, why is it
not enough, or is
it enough, for growth
rates to be positive
and slow and steady?
So what is the magic thing that
happens between a growth rate
of about, what are we at, 1.8%?
WILLIAM B. BONVILLIAN:
Yeah, around 2.
LILY: And about 3%,
which seems to be more
of an optimistic atmosphere.
So what's going on
in that 1%, and do we
need to maybe, for the next
few years, post 2008 prices?
With the global
economy struggling,
do we need to readjust
ourselves to adapt to a lower
rate of economic growth?
MAX: So in the
report, I remember
that they had mentioned
that we should
be trying to push further
and try to keep our growth,
to try to make it faster.
But when I was reading
I felt like, well,
maybe that extremely
high growth rate
was emphasized in the first
place, part of it anyway.
So, at least from what I
see, maybe we should just
try to adapt to
what we have now,
and just keep things
more steady [INAUDIBLE]
we do that it'll
be less intense.
AUDIENCE: So, like kind of stay
on that more gradual slope,
rather than the steep one that
bubbles out and then hits that?
Is that what you're saying?
MAX: Yeah.
WILLIAM B. BONVILLIAN: So let
me take that on for a minute.
Because if technological
and related innovation is
the dominant causative
factor of growth,
and your societal well-being
depends upon your ability
to have that growth and to
spread that well-being across
this society, then if we're
stuck at a one at a 1.8-2%
growth rate, isn't that going
to be an enduring disruptive
problem in this society?
Aren't we going to
be a lot better off
if we could push that up to 3%?
LILY: Is it emotional?
Is it like the stock market,
that's emotionally driven?
Is that what's going on here?
WILLIAM B. BONVILLIAN:
Well, if we've
got a deep problem of
economic income inequality
at this point, an economic
growth rate helps a lot
in dealing with that.
It's much more problematic
to deal with that
with a low growth rate.
For example, this kind of
barbell effect that we've
got in this society of a growing
upper-middle class, and then
a thinning middle, and a
growing lower-end services,
lower-paid services sector
which the middle is being pushed
into, it gets a
lot harder to fix
that unless you've got
a stronger growth rate,
I'd argue.
I understand your point.
How much stuff do we
really need, right?
How many things we
actually have to have?
Is there a whole new way
of organizing this society?
So you're making an interesting
underlying point, I think, Max.
AUDIENCE: Then there's also
the competitive [INAUDIBLE]
competitive piece we're supposed
to be beating other countries.
We need those innovation
waves if we're
going to keep ownership
of technologies.
MAX: Although, in this
more globalized world,
we're all very
connected, which is
why the housing crisis
that really was local
here affected everyone.
AUDIENCE: Yes, on
the other hand,
we definitely see
ourselves as leaders
compared to other countries.
I mean, there's
no doubt about it,
and I think that
there's a real argument
to be made that if
we're not the ones
to do the discovery around
energy, or whatever,
others will.
WILLIAM B. BONVILLIAN: And
the gains are substantial.
A first mover advantage
is substantial.
AUDIENCE: But I
guess I would say
that it's a good
question of how much do
we really need to consume?
LILY: Or perhaps
it's not necessarily
the 1.8% that's
the problem, it's
the one-two punch
of the dot-com,
our technological wave,
or bubble, bursting,
and then immediately
after that having
also a global economic crisis
that compounded each other.
But one of your points
brought up another question
that someone made, and
that is have we identified,
either within the United
States or internationally,
what could be our
next innovative wave?
And is it the same
for the United States
as it is for the
rest of the world,
or have we even
identified it or do we
think we know what it is yet?
MARTIN: The next
wave is probably
going to be biotech as well.
Because what's
happening with biotech
is that there's this thing
called Moore's law, which
is a [INAUDIBLE] every year,
I think, every 18 months
you double your capabilities.
For a lot of bioengineering the
ability to sequence and also
write DNA, [INAUDIBLE]
sequencing,
I forget how fast
the [INAUDIBLE] is.
You might be able to Google
it, I forget what the name is.
LILY: That's what I do.
The Human Genome Project
was over 10 years and cost
billions of dollars,
and now I can
sequence a couple hundred
genomes for a few thousand
dollars.
MARTIN: Those kind of
exponential economics
is what drives the next wave.
But that's a lot like
IT, energy would probably
be like [SNAPS] somebody
figures some key thing out,
and it's all ahead.
Due to the nature
of that market,
because of fusion
and stuff like that,
you could figure out a way to--
LILY: True, but then I think--
AUDIENCE: It's not the
history of energy technology.
LILY: Yeah, I was going to say
something like, for example,
the light bulb.
Yeah, sure, Edison figured
out the light bulb,
but then on top of that, there
was all the infrastructure
and moving over
to that technology
that really spilled over.
WILLIAM B. BONVILLIAN:
So Lily, why don't we
go to Rycroft and Kash.
LILY: It was summarized
by Bill, and I just
wanted to bring attention
to a couple of questions
about Rycroft and Kash.
So one was a closed question.
How do you strike
a proper balance,
or can you identify a proper
balance between encouraging
competitive R&D inside a
single industry or field,
and then for encouraging
this collective learning
that Rycroft and Kash
say is so important?
And I also have a
similar question
is, is it possible
to foster networking
and shared learning while
protecting profits and patents?
Which I think is exactly
what you were saying.
So do we-- yeah.
AUDIENCE: So, while not always
considered the most innovative
field, the oil and gas
sector has actually
come up with interesting ways
to do shared learning with,
like, joint industry
projects where
they have third-party labs
run projects and companies
or buy into them.
And that they all share the
knowledge of information that
has collective good to them.
And I've always thought
it's interesting
that you don't see that
in many other industries,
but it seems like it has a
lot of potential to be useful.
Some of you sign these
confidentiality agreements,
and you recognize
that we all benefit
from understanding this better.
It seems like it could
be widely applicable
AUDIENCE: I think one
thing to note about that
is that oil and gas is
pretty mature heard industry.
And, say, take biotech.
There's a ton of startups
and new companies,
like for example the new IP
battle over the CRISPR/Cas-9
technology, that's huge, because
there's so many different
companies-- like five or six--
things spawned out of these core
ideas and these IP technologies
that they're licensing
from essentially
two different entities.
And whoever gets those rights,
they have to pay money to.
So I think it makes
sense, like to kind
of share knowledge on
a more mature level,
but for early technologies
and early companies
it's hard to say,
because you're still
trying to protect
your market share
and kind of enter
the market that way.
AUDIENCE: Could I
[INAUDIBLE] you?
How do you feel
like that will be
impacted by international
science competitiveness?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, I feel like
international kind of--
AUDIENCE: Again, so
I probably should've
framed that a
little bit better, I
think the context of
CRISPR technologies,
it's primarily domestic right?
It's really Berkeley
and MIT who are really
fighting for the patent.
So in that instance,
what do you think,
in terms of this
particular technology,
is the role in
international competition
or is this a conflict that
can be resolved domestically--
in another more
innovative way that
does not involve patenting?
I don't know if
that's too much--
AUDIENCE: So I think the fight
also kind of extends to Europe,
just because there has been
some patents filed there.
I don't know too much about
the legal stuff necessarily,
but I think especially
since CRISPR
is kind of like the new
frontier for biotech and medical
technologies to really get
into the genome editing
and could be really
applicable to a whole bunch
of different subfields
and applications
that actually about lot labs are
working on here and elsewhere.
So I think it's also
kind of international,
just because companies abroad--
I'm sure Germany and other
big biotech companies
there are probably interested
in probably working them,
like right now.
WILLIAM B. BONVILLIAN:
Right, and just
to add a point to this IP point
that you all have been raising.
So in our panoply of direct and
indirect innovation factors,
this whole world of intellectual
property rights is indirect,
but we can all see how
potentially significant
it could be.
In other words, it's not
going to fundamentally affect
your ability to undertake
the innovation itself,
but it sure may
affect your ability
to realize gains off of it.
MATT: Can I ask a quick
question about the--
you mentioned the
advantage of a first mover,
and so Nelson was saying
that the first firm doesn't
necessarily get most
of the economic gains.
To me intuitively,
especially where
it's something
like energy, where
you're maybe the first person,
and you're setting up a bunch
nuclear plant, you get stuck
with outdated infrastructure,
and you can't change that.
So could you elaborate
a little bit on that?
WILLIAM B. BONVILLIAN:
Matt, I agree with you.
I think the distinction
here, and I probably
should have been more explicit,
but the first-mover advantage
in launching an innovation
wave, in other words
a national or regional advantage
for the benefitting economy,
I think is very real.
I think the point you made,
that the first-mover advantage
for a particular firm may
be much more questionable.
Others may see
what they're doing
and be able to make
improvements and bring those out
more rapidly than the initial
firm that's kind of locked
into its initial approach.
And we see in many cases,
with new inventions that
bring on innovation
advances, we can certainly
see firms that have a
first-mover advantage.
We can also see second movers
that are able to capture that.
So I think it's a more complex
question at that company level,
but I think it's clearer
at the regional economy,
national economy kind of level.
So I would argue that the US,
by building strong innovation
capacity and its ability to
lead most of the innovation
waves of the second half
of the 20th century,
that was a huge advantage.
That was a huge gain.
So no sooner did the US miss
the quality manufacturing wave
to Japan in the '70s and
'80s, but it came right back
with the IT innovation wave in
the '90s, which Japan missed.
So when you put your economy
at the edge of the frontier,
leadership of the frontier,
capturing those innovation
waves becomes pretty important.
But I digress, Lily.
LILY: We have 45 minutes
total left, which
would mean 15 for each of us.
WILLIAM B. BONVILLIAN:
Why don't you
give us a closing thought
on Rycroft and Kash.
LILY: OK.
Yeah, I thought they needed to
be more explicit with what they
were actually saying,
as someone who
doesn't come from an
economics background,
the terminology was
hard for me to get past.
WILLIAM B. BONVILLIAN:
All this learning
by doing was a
little too squishy.
LILY: Yeah, exactly.
WILLIAM B. BONVILLIAN: Right
you need a more exact portrait.
LILY: I need my terms defined.
WILLIAM B. BONVILLIAN: Got it.
OK, well, I think
that's a valid critique.
All right.
So I'm going to race
through the next couple,
which, Martin, I
think you've got.
MARTIN: Yeah.
WILLIAM B. BONVILLIAN:
This is Egils Milbergs
and I'm not going spend
a lot of time on it.
But again, it's one of these
indirect factors that turns out
to have some significance here.
His point is the old economy
was a world of tangible assets.
What counted were your plant,
your equipment, your land,
your physical resources,
your product inventory,
your infrastructure, support
system, physical stuff.
In the 21st century
of a new economy,
intellectual and intangible
assets, those are key.
So we have a wonderful 19th
century accounting system.
It's really wonderful.
Can really value
the old economy.
It really can't value
the new economy.
And we've been discussing this
whole problem with the ability
to get capital on the advances.
If you've got an
accounting system that
can't value true value in the
new economy, then of course
you're going to have a
serious problem getting
capital funding available.
So here's an indirect
thing, you know,
the accounting
system, that turns out
to have a fairly
significant effect.
So the inability to
measure intangibles
undermines the
willingness of firms
to invest in innovation
because they can't really
score it and get gains from it,
and it limits the investment
flow into innovation
as a result.
So, and he argues,
paints a picture,
of how this intangible
process came about,
arguing that by the late 90s,
looking at the US economy
overall, it was about
$1.1 trillion invest
in intangible assets in
the manufacturing sector.
In that same sector, there
was a trillion dollars in
combined in R&D business
processes and software.
Much more intangible.
And intangible
capital, he argues,
became 82% of US
firms' market value,
just an overwhelming portion
of their market value.
So we need new
metrics for how firms
invest in these qualitative
innovation factors,
so that we can drive
investment in an efficient way
and to the right places and
we just don't have them.
We only measure a
couple of things.
We measure total
company R&D investment--
that gets reported
on quarterly reports,
and we get company
patent filings--
that gets revealed as well.
But then all this other
stuff, and maybe these
aren't the right factors.
Maybe some of them
are completely wrong.
But there's a whole set of
other potential measures
we don't even ask for,
or even think about how
they could be best organized.
So that's Egils core idea here.
That's why you need to get some
of these indirect innovation
factors right, along
with the direct ones.
Another example.
This was Udayan
Gupta's early book
on venture capital, kind of
an early history of venture
capital.
It came out in 2000.
Venture capital, by 1999,
had grown from $3 billion
at the beginning of the
decade to $30 billion.
Now venture capital in
2015 was $60 billion.
So venture capital
was built on the idea
that introducing
new technologies
delivers much higher
investor returns.
Remember that chart
that one of you
cleverly asked me how many
years it covered, was that--
that was Martin?
This is, he's saying
the same thing.
In other words,
if you can capture
the gains of radical investment,
they can be really big.
And that's what
the venture capital
sector is organized around.
And he notes this
interesting history.
So we're in one of the
capitals of venture capital,
we're in the place
that originated it.
The East Coast model originally
was much more focused
on what we would call, today,
financial engineering--
you know, tax benefits,
short term returns,
that conceptual framework kind
of dominated the early Boston
venture capital model.
The West Coast developed
a very different model
around science and
technology-driven growth
in places like Sand Hill
Road and Silicon Valley,
it's still its capita.
So now those distinctions
have pretty much disappeared.
Both sides are in the same game.
And you include within the
term of venture capital,
some people include a
much broader phraseology,
including angel investors,
corporate venture firms,
foundation venture
firms, sometimes
university endowment
funds, that go
to a venture kind of purpose.
So it's a bigger landscape than
it was at the early stages.
But the East Coast
model, which did things
like late-stage buyouts,
turnarounds, roll-UPS,
consolidations, in addition
to early-stage venture.
That's now prevalent, frankly,
in both the East Coast and West
Coast models.
So the two sides
have kind of merged.
The originator of the
venture capital idea
was General Georges Doriot,
who was World War II general,
helped in the
organization of industry
in Europe during World War
II and following it, so
a remarkable figure.
He taught at the
Harvard Business School,
but he's the one who kind
of saw this potential gain
from innovation-based growth.
And the West Coast model really
was kind of a maverick model.
It was very high-risk
investment based
on quite unproven technologies,
and that turned out
to be the right model.
The problem is we're
not frankly doing enough
of that in enough
areas, and we'll
get to that at another
point in class.
So that's the venture capital
story, and let me just close,
and then we'll have some
dialogue that Martin will lead.
This is Charles Schultze, who
was quite a famous economist.
He was budget director
for Lyndon Johnson
and for Jimmy
Carter, who is head
of the Council of
Economic advisors.
Very highly thought of
economist from Minnesota.
Deep historical role in
governmental policymaking.
He's taking a look
at the debate--
which will actually get
into our next class--
about what's going on with
Japan's economy of the 70s
and 80s, where they're
bringing on this new innovation
wave of quality manufacturing
and the US is trying
to figure out how to respond.
And he's talking about
the political debate,
much as we were talking about
the political debate that's
going on now, he
was talking about
the current political
debate of that time
when he writes this in 1983.
And there was a big debate
over US competitiveness.
There was a deep concern
that the US was, guess what,
de-industrializing.
Sound familiar?
That essential US heavy
industry was in decline.
And the 80s concern was that the
US may have been at the cutting
edge of technology advanced,
but it was not implementing
those technology advances.
Whereas, by comparison, the
US perception of the time
was that they had a very
activist governmental kind
of role, an interventionist
governmental kind of role,
that's identifying
technological winners
and moving those right
into implementation.
So in a way, Martin,
it's like the point
you were raising earlier.
Don't just do
sculptures, do buildings.
Japan was deep into
the building phase.
The US was still at
the sculpture phase.
And its principal arm
for doing this was MITI--
which is now called METI--
but still very prevalent.
But considerably less
interventionist now
than it was back
in the 70s and 80s.
What proposals are
the parties coming up
with on how to deal with this?
Well, here's what the
Democrats were up to.
They decided there should be
an industrial development bank.
It would, just like
in Japan, pick winners
and, heaven forbid, it
would protect losers.
So no one would have to lose,
jobs would be protected,
and so forth.
And yet they would also
select winning new areas
to get investment.
And it would work to rehab
failing major industries,
upgrade them, protect
their workforces,
but also attempt on
working on a new labor
agreement between
management and labor
to get labor cost
cuts that would
help fund the restoration
of these sectors.
That was the Democrats idea.
The Republican idea was to--
you guessed it-- support
reductions in marginal tax
rates.
Schultze is very
concerned about this idea.
His concern is that the
US government is not
able to select a winning
industrial structure.
This is just not a good job
for government to be doing.
It will not be good at this.
The regional politics,
the state politics,
are just so powerful
that it's going
to unglue the
government's ability
to pick a winning technology
sector and ride with it.
It's going to have
to be dispersed,
everybody's going to
have to have gains,
jobs are going to have to be
located all over the place.
Just not something that's
going to be supported well,
that the political system
really cannot efficiently choose
between individual firms,
and particularly regions,
for getting support at this
stage of the industrial
process.
So find and support
R&D, but when
it comes closer much
further down the pipeline
and you're actually picking
industrial winners, that's
a really tricky political
process he warns us about.
So a lot of this
class, as you all
were driving us
towards today, is
going to be what is
the governmental role.
So Schultze stands
as a warning about
the political imperfections
of government,
the political
difficulties of government
in undertaking an
interventionist role.
So I think that's probably
a pretty good since we all
skipped the rest of
Schultze, but that's
really his core
idea, is to tell us
a cautionary tale about what
the governmental role is going
to be.
That the sheer massive
weight of politics
is not going to necessarily
drive optimal technology
decision-making.
Now.
Martin, let me turn
it over to you,
and let's go
through these three.
So first Egils,
and then maybe do
a couple of questions on
that and say some points,
and then let's do Gupta on
the venture capital structure.
MARTIN: Just do like
a general overview?
WILLIAM B. BONVILLIAN: Yeah,
let's just have an overview,
and we'll start with
Milbergs, and then
go into a couple of questions.
MARTIN: The objective
is to increase incentive
for private sector, especially
long-term, innovation
strategies and
investments, but that
can be pretty difficult to do.
Market values are driven by
economic conditions, demand,
potential market
size, and profits.
Various [INAUDIBLE]
competitors reason [INAUDIBLE]
alternative substitutes.
But intangible
assets most likely
will determine the long-term
success of a company.
It has to do a lot with
their corporate strategy.
Most likely, the
company that we see
that are successful
today that are going
to be successful
100 years from now
won't be doing the same thing.
An easy example
would be if you look
at what Monsanto, originally
they were a chemical company,
and now they're
focusing on agriculture.
So I know a few of these
long-term innovation
strategies, on these things
that are hard to measure.
And so a couple of
questions that were left up
were, what innovation trends
and sectors represent the most
promising growth areas
for VCs in the few years?
What can incentivize the shift
to long-term intrinsic value
creation compared to
short-term objectives?
If anybody has any interesting
insights or experiences
that just kind of [INAUDIBLE]
Feel free to share them.
Rasheed: I think
about, particularly
the old accounting
system, which is
kind of measuring money flows,
financial engineering which
is kind of important, I think
that might have been easy--
I guess it was easy and so
it's easy to probably think
of it as easy because you
were doing it for so long.
But I think particularly
in valuing its intangibles
as something that
we see is going
to be create all this growth.
And then, I don't know if
there's any management studies
or kind of behavioral things
that we can take a look at how
are we doing at
these intangibles,
because these intangibles
seem like something like,
you know it when you see it.
You might not be able
to put bounds on it,
or put a number on it.
I feel like it's because
we haven't tried.
And so I don't
know if there have
been any efforts sustained,
or even accepted,
or even argued over, to start
valuing these intangible things
as we can complain all we want
about how we can't measure
the intangibles [INAUDIBLE]
WILLIAM B. BONVILLIAN: So,
Rasheed, a very interesting
point.
And there's been a significant
amount of work in Britain,
actually, to try and figure
out measurement systems
for these intangibles, these
kind of know-how based assets.
And then following
from that work
in the EU on trying
to measure these.
Interestingly, we really
haven't done much in the US
on this, as crucial as it is.
AUDIENCE: Because I think
it's really important
to have some sort
of standardized way
to measure this, because
otherwise it all comes down
to trust between
companies and investors,
and companies will always have
an incentive to overstate what
their intangible assets are.
And because they're
intangible it's harder
to prove whether they're
being honest or not,
so there needs some sort
of standardization process.
AUDIENCE: On the other end, like
from an investing standpoint,
isn't the fact that valuing
intangibles and things
like IP, the main
reason why there could
be like hidden value or
of mispricing based on,
because not everyone
has a good idea of how
to price these things,
that's how they can find sort
of an edge based off other
companies that might not
have the same insight.
I feel like that might
be one of the reasons
why there hasn't been
a push to kind of,
I don't know, standardize,
how to quantify those-- not
only because it's difficult to.
Especially, like, I
think he brought up
like customer satisfaction.
I feel like that's really
hard to figure out a way
to come up with a
metric to say, oh,
this customer satisfaction
is higher than this one.
I feel like it'd be
difficult but interesting
to come up with a system.
AUDIENCE: I was also
curious whether he's
talking about a system that's
applicable to companies
in different industries,
or just companies
within the same industry.
Are you looking at
Dropbox and Box,
or are you looking at
like Dropbox and Facebook?
Can you actually
compare across--
not even the same industry, but
across like applications, even.
MARTIN: Another
interesting question
to add onto that is,
why are we treating
intellectual property for
different industries the same?
I think the lifetime of a
pattern is around 20 years,
and so why is it
that something that
is really easy or relatively
easy to do that [INAUDIBLE]
as a patent for IT, like for
Facebook, where it's very
quick to capture value
relatively to other industries
versus like energy, where
they might take you years
and years of research to do it.
And then even to
execute, 20 years
is a short time frame because
it might take you 10 years
to negotiate where
you're going to put it,
right, if you're doing
a reactor system.
So by the time you
kind of get started,
there's incentives there
to now really focused
on those industries.
So even biotech, where I
think it's around a billion
to $2 billion to create a drug.
Why aren't there longer
intellectual property cycles
for those industries,
in order to incentivize
more growth in those areas?
MATT: So I mean, the 20 year
thing is a general framework,
but there is for
pharmaceuticals,
there are patent
laws that will extend
the lifetime of your patent to
compensate for some of the R&D.
But they do exist.
WILLIAM B. BONVILLIAN: When
we do a class on the life
science, health science
kind of case study,
we'll get deeply into this whole
question about patent term,
and could you start
to vary patent term,
to encourage small-market drugs,
third-world disease drugs which
wouldn't ordinarily come
about to the system.
Where you're right, our
team, we've got to capture
a [? billion-eight ?] just
upfront in order to bring
a drug to market.
MARTIN: Did anybody have
any interesting thoughts
or disputes or any ideas
they wanted to express?
[INAUDIBLE] Can you put
on the Doriot slide?
WILLIAM B. BONVILLIAN: Sure.
MARTIN: So originally, venture
capital started, the story
is that William Shockley
came up with the transistor.
He won a Nobel Prize for it,
but then he got really cocky.
And he had all these
brilliant people,
he acquired the best
talent in the nation, PhDs
from MIT, Stanford at
the time, and they all
came to work for him.
But he was such a bad boss
that all these great minds felt
under stress working for him.
They were called the
Traitorous Eight,
and they chose to leave him
and start their own company.
What they did is they wrote
a letter to this guy called
Arthur Rock, who was a
Wall Street financier,
and they asked him if they
could get some funding
to create their own company.
And they had a strong
IP and strong knowledge
of the industry.
And he got the funding.
So that was the beginnings
of venture capital.
It really didn't speed up until
the 90s and the IT revolution,
because originally venture
capital was very much
a long-form capital.
What happened is that
you would invest money,
and you expected it-- they were
going to get a core capability,
they were able to reap profits
for long periods of time.
But that changed when
the IT religion hit,
in that it could be a fast
way of making a return.
And so a venture capital fund
became a lot like hedge fund,
and it took a lot more risk.
So pretty much the
way a VC firm runs
is they'll last round 10 years.
The way they work is that
they focus on outliers,
and winning with outliers, so
pretty much what they'll do
is, they'd give
each of us about--
well, I'll just keep
the same figures--
so they'll give us each like
a seed round of about $100,000
to a million, but they
only expect one of us
to really become
like a Facebook.
And they know that every
single year there's
probably only like
10 companies that you
should invest in that are
going to be the big winners.
And they focus on these
multiple high-factor returns.
If you make less than 15x
to your original investment
as a VC, you're
considered a bad VC.
And there's still only
like a couple of VCs
that are known as the
really, really good ones,
and what they focus
doing nowadays
is not just getting you money.
They actually focus on
helping you build out a team.
And in that paper they
actually talked about,
we look a lot at the
technology but also the person,
because pretty much we're
going to help you grow
this company like it's a jet.
It's going to be
changing rapidly.
You're going to have
[INAUDIBLE] the person
during each phase of it.
And so this is a form of capital
that has become very popular.
If you look into the, I think
we have some of the numbers
there for how much was raised
every year in terms of funds.
WILLIAM B. BONVILLIAN: I got it.
MARTIN: A billion in
1990, $30 billion in 1999,
and 2015, $60 billion.
So there is kind of
a VC capital bubble,
and it's really
illogical because there's
only ten companies you
should really invest in that
are going to make huge returns.
At the same time,
though, because it's
a really great business, or it
seems that way, a lot of people
are putting in money.
So there's bubble-ish behavior.
And so, couple
questions from that era.
What innovation
trends and sectors
represent the most
promising growth areas
for VCs in the next few years?
Any questions about VC capital?
LILY: Yeah I do, actually.
It's Lily.
So you said that
in the first round,
or like the younger VC
capital, a few years ago,
the expectation was
for longer return.
Now we've been spoiled
with the tech revolution
and people want returns on a
two-year, two- to five-year?
Is that reasonable?
MARTIN: More or less.
Like, if you're a
really great company
you're going to exit to an
IPO in about seven years, ten
years.
So that's what
we're looking for.
LILY: Can VC have funds that
mix, long-term and short-term?
Is that what they're
going to have to do,
because I see short term
and this huge influx.
Look, we have
excess capital now.
If you say that there are only x
number of companies that really
hit it big in the short-term,
we have excess capital as
compared to previous years.
So do you think
that VCs are going
to have to start paying more
attention to long-term returns,
and is that a more sustainable
business model for them?
MARTIN: So what's
happened is, it's
not so much like VCs in
terms of making return,
because the way a VC fund works
is that they'll acquire money
from, say, MIT's funds.
And then you increase
that capital.
So a lot of times
they can't say,
oh, well, we're going to focus
on this and it's much better,
it's going to be net profitable,
but not in terms of money.
It'll be good for society.
That doesn't really happen.
What ends up happening,
recently there's
been a fund that's like
that, that was invested where
the investors are Jack Ma
from Alibaba, Bill Gates,
I forget the name of it--
Breakthrough Energy-- and they
focus on longer time cycles
of around 20 years.
And also they focus on having,
it's pretty much like the dream
team of billionaires on it.
AUDIENCE: And they
announced it a year ago
and they've now formed
the pool of money,
but I have yet to hear about
any actual investments.
MARTIN: The reason
I bring that one up
is because it's not so much
that they're trying to make
huge returns on capital.
What they're doing is a mix
of philanthropy and venture
capital.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
patient capital.
MARTIN: Yeah.
MATT: So, related to
that, I'm sure you
know that there are VC
firms that will only
do a Series A financing,
Series B financing,
or Mezzanine financing.
And there are firms that
would do a mix of that,
at different stages
in companies.
But then you run
into the upper limit,
where you have groups
like the [INAUDIBLE]
I'm working on where
venture capitalists don't
want to wait more than 15 years
or so to [INAUDIBLE] a return.
AUDIENCE: So I've heard
of the number of funds,
especially in Silicon Valley,
that aren't just like solely
VC now, but are also like
long/short equity funds,
like more of a hedge fund
style combined with VC,
so it's sort of like--
VCs more longer-term
horizon like two
to five years or whatever.
They're willing to wait out
for but also in the short term,
playing around with getting
some returns that way.
So I think that might
be a response to how
to address that
problem with what to do
with a longer-term horizon.
Rasheed: Is it also just
really early to tell?
Because I guess the
idea is you see firms
and [INAUDIBLE] So I guess
we're probably not slowing down
according to this one
venture capital group
but like, is it kind
of hard to see out,
you know, these firms
are now starting
to pop up who are willing to
invest out past 15 towards 20
years, and is it a little
bit early for us to say maybe
these firms might have more
success or less success
than the traditional model?
Because it really
is just really new
and they haven't made
a single investment.
AUDIENCE: Well, and
the percent of VC money
that this represents is small.
WILLIAM B. BONVILLIAN: Yeah
just to put a few numbers
on the table.
So, venture capital funding
in 2015 was $60 billion.
Venture capital funding
before the great recession
was about $60 billion as well.
So we're sort of
back to that number.
But when you,
think about, I mean
after all, if growth is driven
by technological and related
innovation, and you've get
$19 trillion economy, say,
nationwide.
$60 billion in nothing.
That's not a lot of
money to be banking
on what our future
growth is going to be.
So the issue I think
Martin shrewdly raised,
was we're not on an
innovation wave at the moment.
We're on the kind of
scale-up part of the IT wave.
It's not the 1990s anymore.
VCs really work
amazingly when they're
right on the cusp of
an innovation wave.
And playing for that very
rapid scale-up in growth so Art
Rocks' investments
in intel-- which,
you're absolutely right
Martin, did drive the creation
of the West Coast model--
that was just at the
cusp of the IT wave.
And the VC firms really
rode it, and we're not
on one of those
ways at the moment.
So the VC model has gotten
much more complicated,
because the number of
firms that are actually
going to carry the kind of
rewards that occur typically
in the fast scale-up part of the
innovation wave is just slower.
Things are slower.
We're waiting for the
waves, right, like surfers.
And I think the old
model, the maverick model,
will come right back if we
get onto one of these waves,
but as we've discussed
these are typically
40-year-long propositions.
And you can be in a long
trough before a wave takes off,
so that's the fundamental
question for this industry.
On the other hand, maybe there's
another way of looking at it.
Maybe the other way of looking
at it is, could you spur waves
more rapidly, and is
the short-term return
model of venture capital a
real barrier in our ability
to stand up longer, stronger,
more enduring innovation
waves sooner?
So there's a couple of ways
of looking at this that I
think are intriguing.
And we're going to we're going
to take a dive into venture
capital later in the
class, kind of looking
in little more detail, too,
as you suggested, Matt,
about the engine.
MARTIN: Yeah.
I was going to bring up, there
is one venture capitalist
that focuses on the longer
time horizons, about 40 years.
His name is Peter Thiel.
Actually the whole idea
that we are kind of
like a technological
recession is from him.
He talks a lot about
how we're not really
increasing our
capabilities, and he's
famous for having
this one quote that
goes something
along the lines of,
we were promised flying cars,
but we got 144 characters.
WILLIAM B. BONVILLIAN: It's one
of my favorite quotes, Martin.
I was going to use it too.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
MARTIN: The thing is, if you
looked into the '50s and '70s,
or if you look at
the comic books,
if you look at Iron Man and
all different characters,
they show this
feature where energy,
flying into the
air, enough water,
we're not focusing on resources
and resource wars anymore.
And what kind of
ended up happening
is we have the IT wave
but now we are even more
pessimistic, right?
And so his point of view is
more that we have better things,
in some sense.
But in terms of having these
long-form kind of technologies
that have a huge impact on our
society, we haven't had that.
It's just really good times
for this one technology.
And that's his main proposition.
But he does focus on
these technologies
that are a longer timeframe.
And that might actually
be a huge opportunity,
because if, you know, $59
billion of the capital
are focusing on these ten
year sexy chat companies,
like Snapchat, Facebook,
Pinterest, that really won't
have a big impact, and you're
one of the investors who goes,
OK, I'll wait 10
more years, but I
have kind of trillion-dollar
companies, that are coming off
[INAUDIBLE] That's
a huge opportunity.
The big thing, too, is we were
talking about entrepreneurs
and how the first
inventor usually
doesn't capture that value.
This is actually an opportunity
for maybe the first inventor
to capture a lot of
value, and then people
focus on that becoming the
first wave of venture again.
But the drawback of
that, too, is that, say,
somebody in this room discovered
some great technology,
but you still have like a
semester worth of school,
or something like that.
You want to stay at
MIT for an extra year.
Somebody could
see the technology
and go to Silicon Valley,
raise $1 million, $3 million,
and they get the scale.
The Silicon Valley model
isn't first to invent,
it's first to scale.
Facebook was the 15th social
network invented, pretty much.
You've got some notoriety.
So that's another big thing
is that maybe that divide
between the first wave and
the second wave of invention
is going to get either
smaller or bigger.
Just because you have
these kind of Wall Street
hyper-rapid effects.
WILLIAM B. BONVILLIAN: Right.
So you're driving us, I think,
to an important point, Martin,
about the venture capital
sector as it's organized now.
It's really organized for
this, that's what it wants.
It doesn't know what
to do with this,
and it's desperately trying
to make this look like this.
That's kind of where we are.
There's a problem
with his model.
It's not there.
And so just as we critique the
Merrill Lynch piece for the gap
here, and longer-term
patient capital,
it turns out that the
VC model isn't really
helping us where we really
need a lot of help, which is
more in this kind of territory.
Chloe?
CHLOE: I wonder if some of
that comes from, in this piece
especially, there seemed to
be a lot of obsession of,
like, building the right
team, and all the right stuff
will come if you have the
right billionaires all
in the room together, just
a small number of people.
And it's probably easier to
ask for a lot in a short period
of time from people, because
their career lifespan
is much shorter than the
lifespan of a technology.
It would be easier to
look a person in the face
and be like, develop this for
me right now, because, you know,
your career is 20 years long.
Not your career, but that
billionaire [INAUDIBLE]
so maybe that's why their
current model is more
suited for the fast growth,
when actually they're
in slow growth mode.
WILLIAM B. BONVILLIAN: Yeah, so
I mean, Martha was pushing us
and Martin you
mentioned it as well,
this whole Gates has
organized this new group
that wants to deal with
exactly this problem.
They want to start dealing
with some of this stuff,
not just trying to focus on
this in order to get an energy
innovation wave going.
So that may be big enough
to be a different model.
I don't know.
It's not $60 billion and
it's a long way away from it,
but he is shaking down
people with a lot of money.
AUDIENCE: So, Bill and Martin,
isn't the VC model working
just fine for the VC firms?
I mean, Lily mentioned, hey,
there's more capital out there.
I'm not sure that's true.
I think it's-- aren't
they doing just fine?
WILLIAM B. BONVILLIAN: Yeah.
It's fine.
As long as all we want
is software and biotech,
it's great.
AUDIENCE: I just wanted
to check on that.
WILLIAM B. BONVILLIAN: Right.
It's great!
It's fabulous!
And some services sectors.
Media and entertainment
are good too.
But if the society
wants some other stuff,
right, then we've got a
serious problem on our hands.
AUDIENCE: And Bill Gates has
taken it upon himself to find--
WILLIAM B. BONVILLIAN: The
energy solution for the world.
Right.
Because energy is a huge loser
in the current venture capital
market.
MARTIN: I mean another
thing to consider too,
is that these institutes--
they're more like institutions
now.
Like, there's only
really five that matter,
like Sequoia Capital, Andreessen
Horowitz is one of the top
ones, what's it
called, there's--
AUDIENCE: John Doerr's group.
MARTIN: John Doerr's
[INAUDIBLE] something like that?
So yeah they're kind of
like the MITs and Harvards.
Also if you're
getting investment,
you want it from
one of the top ones,
because you have to get
multiple rounds of funding.
So if you get your first
round and and investor
doesn't matter, isn't
that important, it's
going to make it so much
more difficult [INAUDIBLE]
that will matter in the future.
But another thing too is
that Silicon Valley, which
is the cool thing
is like they come up
with all these ideas on how
to structure teams and make
innovation.
They focus a lot on
disruptive business models,
so what might be interesting
is if somebody who focuses on
like a harder industry
and the energy sector,
right now we could
say that they're
a lot like the early
telegraph lines,
that they're everywhere, right?
But it's only focused still
on building the mobile phone
for energy.
Or it's something
that's very modular.
You have these disruptive
angles with technology.
And so the top like
fusion startups right now
they're focusing
on something that's
the size of a truck or
a reactor that's mobile
and stuff like that.
But you probably know a
lot better than I did.
MAX: Yeah, that's
Lockheed Martin.
MARTIN: Lockheed
Martin's is indoor.
I'm talking about Helion.
That's the one that YCombinator
or someone invested in.
WILLIAM B. BONVILLIAN:
Even YCombinator
is only two years down.
All right, so I'm
going to push us to--
why don't you give us a few
comments on Schultze and we'll
close out the session.
MARTIN: OK I wanted to
link Schultze to this idea,
too, because should the
government be a VC bunch, maybe
focusing on let's pick
the winners and the losers
when inherently, that's
not their nature.
In general you're looking
for the wellfare of society,
and there is a market failure.
Another big aspect, too,
is they've done better--
well, Schultze's main
point is that economies
have done better when the
government gives a supportive
role, and he does talk
a lot about Japan.
I think another factor
to consider for Japan
and also South Korea, because
I don't think he brought up
in his paper, but his ideas
kind of align with that,
is that their population
periods were in a certain way.
Usually you hit into these
industrial high-growth areas
where you have a lot of young
people and very few older
people.
And that's why they kind
of die off very quickly.
So that might be a
hidden factor that he
didn't consider at this point.
But so, yeah.
Is it this idea of, do we
create this for the environment,
or do we focus on industries?
I think it also might have been
Jorgenson in the last week's
class, where he talked about
this idea of specific cities
that focus on
certain industries.
That was very interesting,
especially contrasting
with this point of view,
where we make it easier
to innovate on certain
areas and certain cities
and you develop the
capability for the city
because cities tend
to last longer.
Well, cities tend to have
longer-lasting effects
where people stay there.
LILY: It's funny.
I kept thinking completely
different things while I
was reading the Schultze piece.
I kept thinking, or wondering,
would he be writing--
I didn't look up any of his
later papers or pieces--
but I kept thinking
would he be writing
the same thing if he wrote
it today or five years ago?
Because he keeps-- and I
kept thinking, oh my gosh.
Schultze is the reason we have
the president we have today.
He keeps on telling
everyone we're
not de-industrializing,
don't worry,
we're not de-industrializing.
But we really were, weren't we?
And so, granted, all of
my economic knowledge
comes from Freakonomics,
but I would
say that wasn't this
a pretty popular view?
We're not
de-industrializing, or even
if we are, don't worry,
because the jobs are going
to be replaced by the technology
that we're developing,
and so don't worry, don't worry.
And we really let a
lot of the industry
here get away from us
and to other countries.
And so I just think he
would change his tune
if he were writing it today.
WILLIAM B. BONVILLIAN:
You know, you raise
a very interesting point, Lily.
Schultze's writing in 1983.
Solow doesn't get the
Nobel Prize until 1987,
so growth economics doesn't--
Beth and I were talking a little
bit about this before class--
but growth economics
doesn't really
lock in until really
we start to see
what's happening in the 1990s.
That's when you can't
ignore growth theory,
you see it right
in front of you.
So Schultze is out of
classical economics.
He keeps pointing us to
Japan's success story
being the national savings rate.
Solow says it's useful,
but that's not the driver,
it's this technological
related innovation.
So in a way you can see
Schultze, just as you suggest,
as a dialogue within
different stages of economics
thinking right.
And Schultze, in many ways, is
certainly in the neoclassical
and in a way earlier
classical economics
thinking about growth,
before new growth theory
develops from people
like Solow and Romer.
So that's part of
what he's saying here.
But I do think that his
point about the difficulty
of the political
system to operate
in a sophisticated
technology realm,
I think that's very real.
So every time we--
you know, I'm guilty of this
periodically-- every time we
want to expand the
governmental role
and push it further
down the pipeline,
Schultze always stands
as a warning for me
about the complexity of how
the political process is
going to wrestle with this.
And the reward system
in the political system
is not the same reward system
that technology standup
necessarily needs.
AUDIENCE: Going
off your point, I
think it is interesting
that he mentions,
like, if this were
a problem, these
would be some solutions,
like unemployment
compensation, relocation
assistance, training,
but at the time
it was a problem.
So we can recognize solutions
to potential problems,
but we don't seem to
recognize the problem when
it's rising so that we come
up with other solutions.
WILLIAM B.
BONVILLIAN: So Martin,
a closing thought
for us on Schultze?
MARTIN: I mean, I thought it
was pretty straightforward.
These kind of growth webs are
very tricky for the government
to focus on, and
also to do it well.
But having some kind of
function in the innovation space
is also important to have.
So it's really like
being supportive
of the economic environment,
but if you get too close
you'll burn yourself, in
terms of the complexity.
WILLIAM B. BONVILLIAN:
Good summary.
All right.
I want to thank our three
discussion leaders for getting
us off to such a good start.
Good work, team.
You set a model for us
at a high threshold.
I think now our classes,
the participation
is pretty well settled.
I think we've got a great size.
I can just tell from
the discussion today
it's going to be terrific.
You guys are going to be great.
And I think we're going
to have a lot of fun.
So I had a good time last
week, but I'm really reassured
about where this is going.
So thank you all
for participating.
So I'll see you
on the 28th, and I
will put out a longer-term
list of discussion leaders
in the interim.